من الخرطوم ينضم الينا مدير الاعلام لدى
اللجنه الدوليه للصليب الاحمر في السودان
جيرمن ميوهو جيرمن مرحبا بك معي على شاشه
العربيه بدايه كيف تقيمون الاوضاع
الانسانيه الصحيه في السودان ونحن على
اعتاب دخول الاسبوع الثاني لهذه الازمه
الوضع الانساني في السودان ولا سيما في
العاصمه الخرطوم والكثير من المدن
المتضرره
بالصراع الوضع هو ماساوي
[موسيقى]
للمياه لان المحطات المياه لا تعمل في
الكثير من احياء الخرطوم والناس بحاجه
ايضا للكهرباء
هذه الاحتياجات المهمه جدا للمواطنين
وكذلك للمستشفيات وبالحديث عن المستشفيات
هناك صحفي المستلزمات الطبيه والادويه
والعاملين في القطاع الصحي لا يمكن ان
يتحركوا بامان من منازلهم الى
المستشفيات
ونتيجه لذلك هناك كثير من المستشفيات التي
خرجت عن الخدمه والسبب يعود لانعدام
الموظفين والعاملين والمستلزمات الطبيه
والمياه والكهرباء ان الوضع يسبح اكثر
صعوبه بالنسبه للجميع
وهناك ايضا شحر في النقود والاموال فالناس
ليس لديهم القدره للحصول على النقد من
اجهزه الصرف الالي واغلاق البنوك هذا وضع
يسود ليس فقط في الخرطوم ولكنه موجود ايضا
في الكثير من البلدان بما في ذلك تلك التي
لم تتضرر بالقتال واود ان اشير ايضا
الى ان اسعار
المواد الاساسيه مثل السكر والمواد
الغذائيه هذه الاسعار زادت
بحوالي ثلاثه او اربعه اضعاف وهذا يزيد من
تفاقم الاوضاع بالنسبه للمواطنين ليس هناك
ايضا
الوسيله لاولئك الذين يريدون ان يغادروا
الخرطوم للذهاب الى اماكن اخرى فهناك شحنه
انعدام للوق نرى الاعداد متزايده من الناس
يفرون من المدن المتضرره القتال ويحاولون
الابتعاد عن هذه المدن
وهذا يؤدي الى زياده عدد النازحين في
السودان هذا هو الوضع السائد اليوم
في الكثير من ارجاء السودان ولكن الناس
يعيشون في الخوف لا يعلمون ما يخبئه لهم
المستقبل والى اين سيذهب هذا الصراع طيب
تتحدث عن انعدام الموظفين
ادويه وغيرها من الاحتياجات الاساسيه هل
هذا يعني بانكم لا تستطيعون التحرك لا
تستطيعون المساعده في السودان الان وبانكم
محجمون عن تقديم اي مساعدات بسبب الوضع
الحالي سيد جيرمن
[موسيقى]
المنظمات الانسانيه بالاساس اوقفت اعمالها
في السودان بسبب الوضع الامني لان هذه
المنظمات ليس لديها ضمانات امنيه من طرفي
الصراع
بالنسبه
للجنه الدوليه لاساليب الاحمر فقد قررنا
الخروج من العاصمه الخرطوم
ونعمل على بدل كل ما نستطيع لتقديم
مساعدات الانسانيه الملحه لمن يحتاج اليها
في الخرطوم في هذه الاوقات لانه اصبح من
الصعوبه بمكان العمل داخل السودان اود ان
اغتني مع هذه الفرصه ونتحدث على شاشتكم
يدعو كافه الاطراف هو الطرفي صراع
لتيسير عمل المنظمات الانسانيه
وكذلك حركه العاملين في القطاع الصحي حتى
يستطيعوا الوصول الى المستشفيات وتقديم
الرعايه الصحيه كما ادعوهم لتيسير اولئك
الذين يبحثون عن المياه
التوفير الكهرباء هناك حاجه لصيانه محطات
المياه والكهرباء واذا لم يتمكن
السودانيون من
الاعتناء بمتطلبات
الصيانه لمحطات الكهرباء والمياه هذا
سيؤدي منعدام المياه والكهرباء في ارجاء
متعدده من الخرطوم وكذلك المدل المتضرره
بالقتال هل هناك خطر بيولوجي يحيط
بالسودان هذه الايام بعد ان تمت السيطره
المسلحه على مختبر الصحه الوطني في
الخرطوم
بشكل عام انه
مطلب الزامي ان يوفر الجانبان المتقاتلان
الحمايه للمدنيين والمنشات المدنيه وكذلك
توفير الحمايه لكل ما يهدد حياه المدنيين
هذه الرساله التي
نوجهها
في جهه جهه اغاثه عالميه ندعو كافه
الاطراف الجيش وكذلك القوات الدعم
السعوديه ندعوهم لحمايه المدنيين والبنى
تحتيه المدنيه وكل ما يمثل خطرا على حياه
السكان لكن لم تجبني سيد جرما عن هذا
المختبر البيولوجي هناك يعني الصحه
العالميه تتحدث ايضا بان هناك
من خلال عبر طبعا مديرها الاقليمي بان هذا
المختبر محتل تحت قوه السلاح وبان هناك
يعني خطر محدق بيولوجي بالسودان بعد
السيطره عليه ماذا لديكم من معلومات حول
هذا الامر
ليست لدينا اي معلومات اضافيه
وافضل عدم الخوض في هذا الامر لاننا في
اللجنه الدوليه لصليب الاحمر ليس لدينا
معلومات وافيه حول هذا الامر هل كل
الامدادات الاساسيه المساعدات ايضا حتى
الطبيه
متوقفه تماما في العاصمه السودانيه
الخرطوم ولا يمكن نقل اي امدادات او
مساعدات الى داخل العاصمه الخرطوم حتى لو
من الولايات السودانيه يعني القريبه منها
المؤسف هذا هو الوضع السائد الان
واللجنه الدوليه لسليب الاحمر بالاشتراك
مع كافه المنظمات الانسانيه لا سيما جمعيه
الهلال الاحمر السوداني نحن نفكر
بايصال الادويه والمستلزمات الطبيه من
خارج السودان الى داخله
ونامل ان تنجح هذه المساعي
رهينه
بالضمانات التي سنحصل عليها وهذا ما سنقوم
به في الايام المقبله لتقديم المساعده
للمستشفيات في الخرطوم والمدن الاخرى
المتضرره من القتال حتى نوفر لهذه
المستشفيات الادويه والمستلزمات الطبيه
الهدن الانسانيه
يعني تعتبر بحسب بعض المراقبين بان هدى
هشه لم تصمت تثبيت الهدنه هنا ربما يكون
امرا مستبعدا حتى يعني توفير الضمانات
ربما الامنيه لكم ولكل طبعا المنظمات
الاغاثيه والانسانيه في
السودان او من سياتي ايضا كذلك الى
السودان مستقبلا كيف ستتعاملون مع هذا
الواقع في السودان ماذا لديكم من بدائل
توجد لدينا خيارات لكن هذا يتوقف ايضا على
الطريقه التي يتقاتل بها
الطرفان وكيف سيسهلون عمل المنظمات
الانسانيه التي اوقف الكثير منها انشطتها
في السودان ولكن لا تزال هناك مكاتب
لمنظمات اخرى ويمكن مواصله العمل فيها
ولكن من اجل ذلك نحن نحتاج لضمانات امنيه
من الطرفين المتحاربين هذا هو الخيار
المتاح
والجيش السوداني وقوه الدعم
السريع عليهم تيسير عمل للمنظمات
الانسانيه حتى يتسنى لنا ان نقدم
المساعدات الطبيه
الملحه لاسيما للجرح الذي لهم في امس
الحاجه للمساعده الان وكذلك
لدعم الوكالات التي توفر الماء والكهرباء
لعامه السكان السوداني ازمه النازحين في
السودان الى اين تتجه حسب تقديراتكم
يعني اولئك الاشخاص الذين نزحوا من
منازلهم اليس كذلك من الخرطوم الى الابيض
من الخرطوم الى عدد من الولايات الاخرى
الكثير من الناس على الطرق ينزحون وهما
يغتنموا فرصه وقف اطلاق النار الحالي
لمغادره المناطق التي يرون انها محفوفه
بالمخاطر اذن هناك من يغادر الخرطوم الى
اماكن اخرى اقل عرضه للقتال هم يغار
يغادرون الخرطوم والمدن التي تشهد قتالا
للذهاب الى اماكن اخرى هناك اشخاص
ينتقلون من الفاشر والجنين في دارفور وقد
تضررت
مدينتان من القتال ويذهبون الى ماكينه
اخرى اذا هناك النازحون داخل السودان كما
تمت اشخاص يلجاون الى بلدان مجاوره الى
مصر وكذلك الى تشاد
والى جمهوريه افريقيا
وجنوب السودان واثيوبيا هذا هو الوضع في
الوقت الحالي علاوه على ذلك
قبل تفجر القتال الحالي
كانت هناك الملايين من النازحين داخل
السودان الملايين من اللاجئين ايضا كانوا
متواجدين داخل السودان وهؤلاء غالبيتهم
كان يحصلون على المساعده من المنظمات
الانسانيه وكمنظمه اغاثه دوليه
فقد تم وقف تقديم المساعده وهذا ما يجعل
حياه الملايين من النازحين الداخليين
واللاجئين ايضا يجعل هذا اوضاعهم كارثيه
اشكرك شكر جزيل على الانضمام الي من
الخرطوم مدير الاعلام لدى اللجنه الدوليه
للصليب الاحمر في السودان جيرمن ميوهو
لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب
الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس
التنبيهات